francis do you like playing games no all
right do you like playing
with your phone yeah well there's a
great game you can play both on your
phone and on desktop and it's called
grade shadow legends it's absolutely
brilliant you can get up to 500
different champions
it's building it's fighting it's
storyline it is
absolutely terrific even someone like
you even though it's a very rich game
someone like you can get the hang of it
i like storylines
let me show you actually the graphics
are really good yeah look at that
the combat is incredible and some of the
champions are brilliant as well look at
this one looks like you before you went
on a diet oh yeah it does yeah and that
one looks like your mum
the game keeps improving all the time as
well so this month they released an
update and there's a huge event in it
called the doom tower
the doom tower is what i call my they're
also releasing
14 amazing new champions just in time
for the holidays and there's a whole
host of other holiday themed content as
well
so this is the perfect time to start
playing this game absolutely and what
makes it even more perfect
is the raid team are giving away a new
bunch of free goodies
one of which is a super special new
champion to get everyone started in the
tower
he's called bulwark just like your mind
mate this sounds incredible
how do i play the game all you need to
do is hit the link in the description
and if you're a new player
you will get that super special champion
called forward completely free
50 gems as well nxp booster some energy
refills and even an
ancient shard as soon as you get in game
all this treasure will be waiting for
you here
and if you're quick enough you can even
find me on there under the username kk
trigger and even join my class i've
always thought of you as somebody who'd
have a clan i do
and it's very easy just hit the link in
the description join me and i'll see you
in the game
welcome to this episode of trigonometry
we're [ __ ]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
and a brilliant guest we have for you
today she's a comedian and writer
bridget fetishi welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me i'm very excited
i feel like brilliant is overselling me
a little bit though so
thank you but yes and the way you said
excited was very emotionless as well you
were like
very excited because i was i was still
stumbling around in my head i'm like
brilliant i feel like everybody's gonna
really be disappointed
it was instant insecurity well let's
make sure that happens shall we
bridgette
uh but listen you are uh fascinating and
you know we've obviously we know we have
a lot of mutual friends we've seen some
of the interviews you've done in the
past
and i get the sense and correct me if
i'm wrong that you're sort of a little
bit like us and
you're stuck between two sides you're
not quite entirely sure where you are
uh both sides occasionally go off the
deep end and then when you criticize the
side that has gone off the deep end all
the people who thought you were on their
side have a go at you
like what what's 2020 been like for you
with
being in that position it's it's been
that way
for the past four years and 2020 was
heightened although in many ways it was
easier because i had this four years to
really get comfortable in that position
and at first i wasn't at all and
i don't know exactly what your
experience has been but you
if you come from the left you kind of
swing out and then suddenly
you're talking to all these people on
the on the right wing
and now you're branded as just another
reactionary liberal who got red pilled
and then you're doing the circuit on the
right and they're like yay you know one
of us
one of us and you're realizing that
you're not
exactly one of one of that tribe
either and i think just finding my own
voice and way into asking myself the
questions of what are my values
there are certain things that i share
that
i thought were perhaps more liberal
values and
i think they certainly are but they
might not be shared by
my peers or by the far left anymore
in the way that they were when i was
growing up
and they whether i consider myself still
a member or liberal um
they're they're not considering me that
if if they were dividing up teams
i wouldn't be on their team anymore so
yeah i'd be in the gulag that's fine um
with all my friends
but listen before francis jumps in i i
realized that
we got straight into the politics side
of it but actually uh
for there'll be a lot of uk people who
watch our show who may not be familiar
with your backstory so
maybe tell everybody a little bit of
your journey through life
and how you happen to be where you are
now yeah so
i always wanted to be a writer but i
moved out to la
and i feel like this is similar to a lot
of your guests probably i came out here
to be in entertainment
i was i started doing comedy stand-up
comedy in 2010 i was writing
always hoping to write shows science
fiction comedies
i have a million scripts sitting around
i was doing
all the things you know the things you
do waiting tables teaching yoga
like cliche los angeles check in her 20s
and i continued on that path for a while
i did some traveling around the world
when i to
i took a kind of break from la and
came back i got sober in 2013. i only
mentioned that because it
was it is just a big turning point i
think in my
in my life in general and in 2015
i s i got on twitter in 2013 so i
completely replaced
my alcoholism with twitter and so you
relapse basically
started mainlining the bird and
i i definitely recognized that it was an
addiction but
as far as harm reduction goes i think it
was okay and
from just a just a perspective of i had
been
in la at this point since
uh 2007 this time i was out here when i
was very young
in my uh like early teen late teens
early 20s right after rehab
and i didn't stay sober in that time
but this time that i came back at 27
i was doing the thing for years so
by the time i got sober in 2013. i'd
been
hustling for a while and trying to make
things happen and i went on twitter and
i kind of
realized that i
i could just build an audience and that
that would be
at least there was something that i
could do when i was feeling very
powerless
still running around asking gatekeepers
permission to perform and
that was one of the things i loved about
stand-up comedy nobody could really take
the mic away from you
you could get up there and say
essentially whatever you wanted
and you just had to wait around and and
wait for your turn but essentially it
was very
free and i saw twitter as that same kind
of
medium where i could just make jokes and
say whatever and
try and find people who resonated with
me and
keep building an audience and i decided
to just focus on that
while i was waiting tables and still
trying to sell
scripts etc i got a job
at playboy i sold my first freelance
piece to playboy in
april of 2015. that was all through
twitter
i i always say every ever i should have
named my podcast which is called watkins
welcome i should have named it all of my
friends are from twitter
because all of my friends are from
twitter now
all over the world and i
i ended up getting connected to an
editor playboy they connected me to the
culture
editor i wrote a piece it did pretty
well and then
i wrote another piece i did a couple of
freelance ones i kept begging them for a
column
then they approached me in january with
the brilliant idea of writing a column
for them weekly and so in 2016 i started
writing a column weekly for a playboy
and that was
amazing and anyone who's ever done a
weekly column knows it's a crazy grind
and i loved it
and that was right around
the time that like trump descended the
staircase
and um or his escalator
and everything went crazy in the culture
and i kind of stumbled into a culture
war that i was already
befuddled by i had never heard of toxic
masculinity i had never heard of the
patriarchy i mean i'd heard of it but i
i didn't go to
i didn't go to like college
i didn't learn any of this stuff um
and so i was learning quickly being
online with playboy
and then i started noticing that i was
not
i was censoring some of the things that
i wanted to say
self-censoring and getting kind of
censored
by editors at um playboy
and then i started paying more attention
to politics
and 2016 forced everybody to in america
in particular
and probably every i mean you guys were
on the heels of brexit i was in
london and ireland actually right on the
heels of brexit and everybody was asking
me
if i thought trump would win and i
really saw brexit as kind of the canary
in the coal mine for
america and i was like yeah i think i
totally think he's gonna win i don't
think there's a chance
he's gonna lose and then that happened
and
overnight this person who became
what was fascinating to me as a comedian
was watching
this person who all of the comedians all
the late night
everybody made millions of dollars
and millions of jokes at his expense
while he was running and i kept saying
on twitter
i was like you guys are making this is a
joke now but
he's gonna win and it's not gonna be so
funny to you anymore
and overnight when he did win it went
from this kind of buffoon to
you know literally hitler and that was
the first time i ever experienced what i
didn't even know at the time but what
i've come to start calling is like
narrative whiplash where the mainstream
culture just shifted
the narrative so quickly on a dime and i
was like wait you guys were
making fun of this guy like he was no
big deal so he's either a clown or he's
like
a dictator he can't how do you just
overnight go from
one to the other but you know you can't
really say that in
los angeles if you're trying to be a
writer and get into writer's rooms and
and then i noticed that you couldn't say
you know why can't i say these things
and work in hollywood that
seems ridiculous and that was when the
journey
kind of really began and i think
recently you had carrie
carry on and she was saying i would
rather just speak
truthfully than work in entertainment
and i definitely
had to come to that very conscious
choice
because i did recognize that i knew the
minute i kind of started just
pushing back i i risked um
not being able to work in the mainstream
but i've on the other hand i think we
live in an amazing time for creatives
where you can build your own thing
and there weren't really any gatekeepers
although now with big tech and their
stuff they're they're suddenly acting
like
like the producers and agents and all
the people who run
entertainment so it's it's uh it's
terrifying
yeah i mean it is terrifying i mean
we've all got our own stories to tell
but
let's just go back uh towards when you
were saying that
if you said that you supported trump or
that you
didn't disagree with some of his
policies you wouldn't
get accepted into writer's rooms can you
explain to people who don't know
the los angeles circuit what that means
and what that looks like
so you're not gonna you'll never
know that's the hard thing about the
industry that we're in
you will never be fired because of your
beliefs
you will just not be asked back or
they will find another creative reason
for letting you go
or you suddenly won't hear
from your managers anymore the way that
you used to hear from them
and it could just be that you're not a
big enough fish or it could be that
you know i see what everybody in the
writers rooms and on these shows
is tweeting this is the thing about
twitter is you see what people are
saying
and i know this in this idea that
the the thing that i i loathe is the
i don't feel safe using this as kind of
a cudgel to silence people
and i know that it would only take one
person saying
i don't feel safe she talks to ben
shapiro on twitter
for me to perhaps not get a job if i was
being considered i
obviously don't have any proof or
evidence of this
other than the fact that i don't have
jobs in
writer's rooms but i i don't think
you're even really
um it's so challenging too because
hollywood will go
where the money goes and i do already
see the shift i already see people who
have been pushing back in the middle
you know starting to gain more
mainstream traction andrew schultz is a
great example he has a four-part netflix
series
he they will go capitalism always wins
as i always joke so i'm hope
and now that you don't have to
constantly kind of justify
like the the but trump people who say
anything
to you pushing back against anything
wild and crazy on the left
perhaps there will be more room for
people to take
aim at some of this more insidious and
insane
stuff that's coming out of the left
but yeah i think that it wasn't even
what was interesting was i wasn't even
taking aim at necessarily saying
at the time saying trump i support trump
i don't know
i didn't know anything about his
policies he was so new i didn't even
know he
he didn't strike me as someone who had
an ideology
i still feel that way about him he seems
very much just like grabbing whatever he
can
while he can
and he but i did notice you know one of
the things that
was really obvious to me right away
particularly being a playboy and
hearing all about this kind of toxic
masculinity
and feminism and et uh i called it high
heel hypocrisy
was this the way they would attack
ivanka melania after all of this defense
of hillary oh we're always making fun of
women for what they're wearing for what
they're talking
for the way their hair looks etc and the
minute these two
got any kind of power were running
seriously
for office suddenly they were attacked
with all of the same stuff that these
women had been saying for years
is not an acceptable form of um
you know making fun of a woman or or
judging a woman
and apparently it is acceptable if that
woman
isn't on your team and i just think if
you have principles
you have to apply them even to people
that don't
agree with you or you disagree with or
they're garbage
but that's like a apparently not the way
politics works
well no it doesn't as we all know ivanka
and all that group are white
supremacists they're jewish white
supremacists but
nevertheless white supremacists but yeah
one
but one thing i i i was i wanted to ask
bridgette was
so we've got this we see this now with
you can't say certain things but aren't
comedians meant to be the counter
culture
aren't we meant to be the people
pointing out the flaws
laughing at the things you couldn't
laugh at what went wrong
i i just think it's fear honestly and
it's and
it's fear it's wanting to fit in
and it is being part of an in-group it's
easy
uh to be it's easy to tweet the right
thing
and be and signal that you're part of
that group
and it's interesting because i really
i am all for progress you know i want to
push
i want more people to be
i i want everybody to have the same
access obviously to everything that
everyone has access to it just
seems like a very simple idea
but i don't necessarily think that
pushing other people down is the right
necessary necessarily the way to go
about that
it just seems like a dangerous and also
kind of hypocritical
stand to take and i i don't know what
happened
in comedy it got it just got it's like
it got taken over by the
the alt scene or something like i'm not
exactly sure when
when it's shifted to to the that kind of
idea of clapter as it's been called
where
you're trying to get approval instead of
trying to point out
and again i actually see i'm beginning
to see a shift i'm seeing
people pushing back i think the more
comedians that speak out and are just
like
f this i'm saying what i want the better
it is for everybody the more
conversations
we've been having like this the more the
the more
that people they're going to have to
make fun of somebody and
you can make fun of the right wing all
you want but there's a big
void that's going to be left when a lot
of these people can't make fun of their
favorite
you know sin eater or the orange man
bad or whatever who kind of took up all
this space
so i already see some of the more
mainstream
comedians shifting in that way and
they'll ride in the wake
of all the people who were kind of
fearlessly calling this stuff out
um from for the past four years but
that's not entirely a bad thing if it
means that
we can bring back comedy
because we live in dark times dark times
produce
dark comedy dark comedy is hilarious
it's my favorite kind of comedy this
should be
we should be allowed to say whatever
right now because
everything is so crazy if you can't say
the most
crazy things and call this stuff out and
make fun of it
it gives it too much credence and it
becomes this
religion and that was and that's the
other thing that i think
kind of happened with comedy is that
what what i saw happen and the loss of
credibility with comedians
with media people with the
journalists is that everyone became an
activist
everyone overnight not everyone some of
us
remained idiots but i'm happy to be an
idiot i'm not
an i don't need to be an activist i can
still push for change
and i also think it is my job as a
comedian to like call
out these kind of deeply held
i i always say i'm gonna make burgers
out of your sacred cows anything that's
sacred to anyone i think it's kind of
hilarious
and particularly being able to make fun
of ourselves
and there's this whole kind of warped
um every the the level of sensitivity
that the culture has
does not seem healthy for anyone it
seems like it's causing a lot
more mental illness taking themselves so
seriously and
everything looking for an offense
everywhere you go and problematizing
everything and
walking i mean we are creating a world
of eggshells that everyone's walking on
now i
grew up in a dysfunctional household
that crap is bad for you
like it's like growing up with a you
know an
alcoholic father or something like the
whole culture is like that now the whole
culture
is an alcoholic dad you're like oh crap
is he gonna come home and be funny or is
he gonna come home and beat the crap out
of me because i said the wrong thing
i don't know that's how you just
described twitter very very well haven't
you bridget
that's just how it feels though i hate
that i hate feeling like i'm being
emotionally
manipulated i hate feeling like
you are responsible when i was in rehab
at 19 years old i remember
the the women who were helping me out
said something to me when i said oh
they're all pushing my buttons
and the women who are running the place
the halfway house i was in there like
yeah
and they're your buttons and you need to
take responsibility for them and look at
where they were installed
and why you have them and why you're
getting so
you know why why you're so easily upset
by these things
or maybe it's true they're saying
something that's
not nice but still i should be able to
you know it's the beginning of learning
how to emotionally
have some kind of emotional sobriety and
take care of myself
roger do you think that's maybe one of
the reasons that you find this stuff as
difficult as as the two of us do which
is
uh not for the same reason necessarily
but uh the fact that you've been through
you talk about you know getting sober
going through rehab
you've been through a situation where
you had to admit
as we were talking before we started a
lack of control over certain things in
life you had to
focus on dealing with what you could
affect you had to
go through difficulty you had to accept
personal responsibility
and these things kind of inoculate you
against being hypersensitive against
making everyone else responsible for
your well-being
do you think that that's a part of where
your journey sort of
came to this point i do although i think
it started even earlier being from a
huge irish catholic family where i
always joked that my upbringing was a
roast battle
so i think i come from a family where
it's like oh you're gonna cry about a
bridge
you know that that like my uncle would
say that not like another cousin
an adult would mock you for crying as a
child
and that was the upbringing it was a
very
punchy irish catholic everybody's taking
hits at everybody else
it was very hard to be a sensitive
empath
in our family i saw a lot of my cousins
kind of struggle
when the ones who were just more quiet
and wanted to read and
felt things more deeply you kind of
either
you either jumped in and and learned how
to take it
or you you didn't and
you didn't generally fare well so there
was that
that early upbringing and i'm grateful
for it i'm grateful that i had parents
who were like life isn't fair i'm
grateful that i came from a family
that deeply respected the ability to be
able to laugh at yourself
and that was a primary value that we
were instilled with growing up
and being able to be self-deprecating
and
laugh in the face of tragedy that was
another thing that
my family and my grandparents were just
you know they went through so much my
grandparents on my dad's side in
particular
they were in pearl harbor when it was
bombed my grandfather was in the
south pacific for the entirety of the
war and was blown off
warships and saw kind of horrific things
was in japan when
they were getting all the prisoners of
war i've been reading all of his letters
and
their depression kids and they had such
a great attitude about life
and they they saw some of the worst that
humanity has to offer
and still we're grateful we're grounded
in faith
we're grounded in in the kind of
principles of family first
you don't you don't have followings out
with your family about money you don't
have followings
out with your blood about politics you
just don't
it's it's like where i'm so grateful
that i had that
um backbone kind of instilled and then
yes going through a lot
of self-inflicted wounds many of which
um i you know many choices i made on my
own
and really having to take responsibility
one
i got sober this time at 35 so
the first time i was in rehab was when i
was 19 and then it was a long
journey between 20 and 35 when i ended
up getting sober sober from everything
and i really when i first got sober i
really had to look at the ways in which
i was entitled the ways in which i felt
like a victim and was always looking
to because this kind of stuff really
is the foundation of upholding that
sense of poor me poor me pour me another
drink
so it all of these kinds of feelings
are just not good if you want to stay
sober because essentially they're gonna
lead you to being in self-pity
constantly which is a horrible place
there's so much self-pity everybody
there's the culture is just
so self-pitying and i feel
ironically bad for people who live in
that kind of constant state because it's
not
that's what i don't understand about
this current um
like psychology or wave that's going
through the culture of
victimhood you know there's this idea of
like playing the tape forward
and i just don't understand where this
where does this get you feeling like
you're perpetually offended feeling like
you're a victim
feeling like the world owes you
something not not waking up and asking
how can i be of service to the world
what can i bring to the world
waking up and saying how have i been
like
effed over and who owes me
and how am i how do i get mine
is not healthy you know ultimately it
just seems like it's
it's it will it only leads to more of
that
where's the end of that but don't you
think part of the problem is bridget is
uh
if you look at a lot of these kids who
are saying you know
oh i've been screwed over or this or
that or i'm offended
and you compare it to your grandparents
generation
you know who went through the depression
who went through the second world war
they've had it so easy yeah no it's too
much i mean i've said this i
said i think america is like a trust
fund baby
it's behaving like a third generation
child who came from wealth and it's i
i'm really thinking a lot about this
and i want to write about i i've been
trying to work out my thoughts because
i think everybody deserves a hero's
journey
and it's it's the stories we love the
most
it's the stories the story that's been
told a million times through
all of history it's pretty much the the
backbone of any great story
and in the absence of true struggle
do you self-destruct and create your own
and that's what so much of this stuff
seems so it's so like every time i see
something trending on twitter which is a
perfect example of this kind of
trust fund baby worry or
self-destruction it's it is it's like a
trust fund baby that gets addicted to
drugs so that it can have something to
like
overcome in life and um
i see these things trending a great
example
recently was a
an op-ed that somebody wrote for the
wall street journal
about and he said it was all about the
use of dr
jill biden using dr and then there was a
whole
24 to 48 hour news cycle around this and
the pundits and talking back and forth
and i'm meanwhile very fascinated with
the cause of the famine in yemen because
it's so bad there's so many children
starving
an entire generation is starving and
you would think with all of our outrage
that we could direct it
somewhere like that like that to me is
the stuff that keeps me up at night and
talk about feeling powerless i don't
even
know where to begin like all i can do is
donate to an organization
and hope that it doesn't go to some
criminal who's taking
money and abusing a 501c3
and that it's actually going to help
someone who needs the money
that's really all i can do from here and
maybe
draw attention to it and then i see this
news cycle and i'm like guys
like what a waste of energy there's so
you care about people suffering but
there you you say
and i think that drives a lot of my own
frustration and feeling like
so much of the outrage is disingenuous
because if you really are you're
outraged about this
and like children are starving
still in front of our eyes and you have
a big platform and
why aren't you using it why don't you
take that outrage
about dr jill biden someone got paid to
write that column first of all
in the first place which is bananas to
me and that's probably why it got
written to be fair yeah
and then there was another one in the
new york times yeah because it's all
you know no one's clicking on like the
starving kids no
which is it it starts with us
you know it's our priorities and our
principles
and it is it i get it it's fun to engage
in that kind of
like stupid cultural tennis basically is
like you did a dumb thing and now i'm
gonna say a dumb thing and you did a
dumb thing you know i'm gonna say a dumb
thing
and then i see it too with like feminism
you know the
in in the western world it's like ladies
we have a lot we we are probably the
most privileged women
in the history of women on earth
throughout all of time
but there are still plenty of women i've
been to many of these countries
where they don't have that and maybe we
should try and
help them out or fight for them or at
least support the women in those
countries
who are fighting for their freedoms that
we
take for granted so i do to
answer your question the long way again
um
i think we take an enormous amount for
granted and
even these freedoms that were like free
speech we just take that for granted in
the united states because
it's it's the water we swim in and it's
easy to
let go of something like that if you
don't
understand that people died for it if
you don't understand what it's like to
live in a country that doesn't
have that and suffers consequences when
when they say things that aren't correct
or
allowed or i don't know i'm i'm i'm
i try very hard to be optimistic and
there's
and stay focused on the positive but i
i see like a chilling slide
into i'm just amazed at how easily
people are like
tralala here we go authoritarians take
over
you know like skipping in i'm like
frog in the boiling water is an
understatement of the year
bridget i'm a pessimist so i've got to
say 2020 has been great for me every one
of my shitty little predictions has come
true
and i have never been more smug i've
been i'm absolutely thrilled do you know
what he calls himself
bridget you know what his surname is he
calls himself foster dharmas now
that's how ridiculous it's got
unbelievable yeah
i was having dinner with my with my
girlfriend last night and i and i
referred to myself as that
and i saw a little shot like a little
light in her eyes slowly die
happiest i've ever been everyone else's
misery makes him happy
but bridget let me ask you this because
it's something i've been thinking about
a lot it seems to me like
as entertainment has become politics
politics has become entertainment
that's maybe where the sort of dr jill
biden
you know trees are racist all of the
[ __ ] sort of comes from because
everyone needs that entertainment we
look to
and look at the politicians that we
elect i mean biden isn't the most
entertaining but certainly here in the
uk
we are consistently electing people now
because
they look at music right they're young
they're funny they're this they're that
we're not actually electing men and
women of substance of principle of
of moral integrity of this these sort of
old-school values that we used to think
about you know look
i'm i'm in my late 30s i personally
think until you're about 50 you
shouldn't be anywhere near politics
because you probably don't know what the
[ __ ] you're doing
right right but but we've gone the other
way now if you're in your 50s you're
it's probably way too late you've been
and gone we need to get rid of you
let's get someone who looks good on
cameron you know what i mean
interesting i mean i i think in america
like the olds are just still clinging to
the
to the to the keys of the car
and refused to let go like they're still
like no i'm not giving this up
um i i'm not sure
yeah we have like feinstein's feinstein
whatever her name is i i never know how
to pronounce it
um i always feel like i get it confused
um she's 87.
you know and biden is old
so i feel like we have a lot of but then
we have like the aocs and the squad
coming in
and they they seem very young like i was
an
idiot at that i'm still an idiot i think
probably the sweet spot for
politics is like 40 to 60 and 40 being
young not that you can't get into it but
it's just i really i and i feel like the
more
i learn the
i just don't feel like i know anything
that's really what the last four years
has taught me is i know
nothing like i go i'm like oh famine in
yemen and i'm like that's outrageous
what's causing it and then it's like
jesus i don't know it's like
interfactions and all i would have to
study you know now i know why people are
like dr
jill biden because you have to study
like
the history of a country in order to
understand
what is happening right now i take your
point about the old still holding on i i
so you know trump biden feinstein mitch
mcconnell whatever in america
but look at look at who who the sort of
promising candidates are on the left
it's people like
aoc and the squad etc and equally on the
right it's people like
dan crenshaw uh within the democratic
party people are talking about people
like andrew yang tulsi gabbard these
people are also repeat buddhist
that all of these people are very young
and equally i think the right is going
to produce its own people you know nikki
haley dan crenshaw who i mentioned
people like that
but anyway look maybe we'll just come
back to the entertainment and politics
sort of trading places now
yeah which which i think is a really
interesting point i don't know if you
how you feel about that i i
i i'm not surprised i mean
this has been kind of predicted did you
guys ever read the book amusing
ourselves to death
it came out in the 80s and he basically
said
with the dawn of television and this
visual medium and everything
being entertainment and that this would
happen
that everything everything would become
entertainment
and it would be bad for all of our
institutions
and so and then there was another great
book mediated that came out in 2006
that i refer to in pretty much every
podcast i'm on because
it was he was looking at kind of
philosophically how
all of this mediation is changing our
brains and us
and with the dawn of technology and this
was pre-social media that his book
really came out
and looking at how everything's
personalized
everything is the iphone and it's all
about us
and you can personalize your music and
personalize your settings and your car
and the temperature in your house and
how when the world is flattering you
constantly
you become entitled
and you become kind of you ex you expect
everyone to adjust to you
and the world to adjust to you it's not
an unreasonable expectation
given the way that our technology has
trained us to essentially behave so
i'm not surprised that it's become
entertainment it's
i think anyone who had any kind of
foresight idiocracy is
a great example of mike judge just
seeing the writing on the wall
of everybody ending up in this costco
reality with a reality show president
and um the question
foster thomas is
what is the what is the a what does this
look like
what is this what's what are your
predictions for 2021
and beyond in the next four years say
i i think we are more and more going to
elect people
not on what they say not on what they do
but on their race gender etc
and it's going to become more more of a
valid statement to say
you know as a brown woman of color i
believe this and everybody goes
okay all certain segments go let's yeah
that's great
we will listen to what you say i think
messages is go the message and the
content of what you're saying
is going to become ever more irrelevant
irrelevant yeah
and and that we're just going to be
disappeared in memory hold
i i just think we're going to be it's
going to be ever more about box ticking
i just think that it's ev it's going to
be about categories more and more and
more
and then you're going to go ah so this
person believes or this person
is like this therefore i will
tick that box so for instance i'll give
you an example like
our current chance of exchequer is a is
a asian guy called rishi sunak
right i've had people say oh isn't it
brilliant for diversity
the fact that we have an asian
chancellor of the exchequer despite the
fact that the guy is literally married
to a family of billionaires
right i think diversity do you know what
i mean well
i mean this is the joke i was making the
other day i
i was talking to a friend who's in this
in this industry
and i'm like let's just make some cool
[ __ ] together and she was like
i'm like represent representation
matters and by that i mean
ideological representation you know it's
it's not just just like the the
immutable characteristics that that's
what they might as well be saying
immutable characteristics matter because
that's
really what they're saying it's not
representation you don't give a crap
about representing people who don't
think like you
you care about representing certain like
you said
you know checking certain boxes and
if if that is what you believe it comes
to
i mean that's chilling because there
seem to be
boxes that you check that are right and
if you
don't fall into a box or if you're not
checking those boxes
or if you're pushing back against the
idea
of everything being about checking boxes
you get memory hole right
and you made the point earlier as well
bridget essentially
sort of translating what i heard out of
what you're saying essentially we've got
to a point where
these claims of sexism like you were
talking about different way that
conservative women are treated versus
liberal or whatever left-wing and so
these all these allegations now of
sexism or discrimination they're
actually weapons they're not really
genuine claims about what happened
they're simply a way of achieving your
outcome
that people have now worked out is very
powerful yeah
it's it's a very powerful thing to say
that someone is racist or that someone
is sexist and
it's difficult to defend it's difficult
to deny it's difficult to argue against
and i think that's one of the reasons
i've been so worried about it because
you're sort of making it okay now for
people to go you know what
i am racist you want to call me racist
100 times i am racist and and not even
like
give a [ __ ] i mean james lindsay talked
about us when we had him on
everybody has a sort of [ __ ] point
and once you accuse somebody of
something enough
they just go you know what [ __ ] it i am
that and they actually start to be that
you know that's the kind of danger i i
remember
i went through this when i was in high
school because i moved so much
and everyone called me a [ __ ] when i
moved i'd never even
had sex with a guy it was just the way
women weaponized
it was a way of bullying a woman when
you were a new girl in a new school and
they
and i got to the point where i was like
all right i'll show you [ __ ] and then i
just started
being a [ __ ] i mean i don't know if that
that was necessarily the progression but
there is that
that's one of the things that i've had
to and this is on us
i don't i don't put that on the people
who are bullying me i think that
this is where the idea of being a
reactionary
is true to a certain extent and
dangerous
because i've definitely had to check
myself
in this process of
being kind of rejected from the
the mainstream the left whatever my
peers
and it would be very easy for me to be
like
f all you guys and
out of those feelings of rejection
rejection is a very powerful
motivating force and so
the work i've had to do the last four
years around
a lot of just being just on the personal
level not even on the political
scheme just looking at is this something
i should naturally be reacting to
if i am reacting to it let's get very
clear about why i'm reacting to it
what am i reacting to like in many
instances
i found that i'll be called a
reactionary for being for reacting to
what i see as compelled speech
and so if i can articulate that that
helps me
with and then sometimes it's like oh no
my i'm just reacting because
um because i'm feeling
it's that knee-jerk like oh if you're
going to call me racist enough then i'll
show you racist that
that idea and that idea is dangerous
you know that we have to guard ourselves
against that because it you can
see how it it can they did i remember
reading some study and i don't remember
where it was or who it was and i need to
get much better about these things but
it was all about how
if people are generally put in you know
boxed into a corner
they're they're going to become um
they're obviously going to react and
i've been saying for
like four years the whole um is it good
that we're
having white people focus on their
whiteness like
this seems like a like
i feel like we've been doing a lot right
and that we haven't had them focusing on
this
and is it great i mean ryan long
did such a great job of pointing that
out with the woke versus racist
because it just seems like a dangerous
like do you really want white men to be
defensive about being
white like that seems like a
marble that might not roll in the
direction you wanted to roll into
and it's terrifying because that is it
is reactionary you know you don't
we have to take responsibility for our
own reactions
obviously i'm not um i'm not giving
anyone who's racist a pass
but i do think that there is a dangerous
cultural trend of focusing on race that
will see
that seems to be agitating things
when i felt like actually we were making
tons of progress in
in race relations even just from a
statistical
just completely objective look at it
and do you think that trump is somewhat
to blame for this because in 2016
it accentuated the culture war or do you
think it was already bubbling before he
came to power
yeah i've i've thought a lot about this
because i wasn't paying attention during
the obama years but it seems like
i i was really unaware until
one of the things that i really had to
do during the trump years and it was
very hard to discern
because the media did not cover obama
the way they covered trump
and so i had to really turn to people
who were essentially never tr
never trumpers or principal
conservatives who had been in this space
for a long time and i would say
is this something that obama did that
they're covering as if it's something
new
or is this something that is dangerous
and unprecedented
that is new that trump is doing and
constantly having to evaluate every
single story that came out about trump
through that lens
was a lot of work but it taught me a lot
about
what went on during the obama
administration and how much
obama actually did play into identity
politics and really start
that ball kind of rolling i mean i think
the tea party
sprung up under him you know it was so
this process i think was already
happening
i have i i see trump is just a symptom
of of a lot of that process that was
already happening
and people feeling like they weren't
being heard
you know the most fascinating people to
me and all of
of this time are the people who voted
from
obama to trump and then biden
you know or the the people who were just
like yeah burn it all down or
bernie bros who voted for trump there's
i feel like there's just a lot of
a lot of a lot of reaction in our
culture in general
everyone seems like they're kind of
reactive to everything
well let's talk about the future a
little bit uh and how things will go
uh particularly trying to channel your
optimism the
that i've got him to put up with being
pessimistic all the time so let's get
some positives if we can
let's start with joe biden first uh i
mean we were recording this in uh
sort of mid december it looked it as
[ __ ] look
we're not in america but as far as we
can tell biden has been elected is that
fair to say
uh i believe the electoral college
certified it this week so yes
uh mitch mcconnell congratulations
yeah so yeah i think that that is it's
safe to say that that is the reality
um yeah my question was going to be let
i know people have some disagreements
about it i don't want to get into that
part of it at all
uh but let's operate on the assumption
that biden has been elected
a lot of people i think now accept that
do you think that will
reverse the trend do you think that will
make things better
okay there we go excellent i'm so happy
thank you bridget no i don't think i so
i'm worried twofold now
because you have this enormous
grievance with millions of people
who feel um the election was stolen so
and a kind of figurehead for that and
so you have that which i think will get
progressively agitated um
you're seeing big tech censor more and
more
and try and slap their warning labels on
everything
and not allowing people to really make
up their own minds and
deciding that they need to be then
essentially big tech has become the
nanny state
and that's terrifying i think you'll see
more of that
because as this grievance you know
becomes more agitated
i think we saw it recently even with
youtube where they were saying anything
that
any election stuff that disagreed with
the
idea that biden won it would it would be
you know memory hold or taken down or
whatever and
that only fuels the idea that something
sketchy is going on if you're
you're disappearing all this stuff or
you're you're shadow banning it or
you're
making demonetizing it all the different
ways you can
d platform so that will probably get
worse
and then in the absence of
trump and all of trump's
supporters i worry that the pitchforked
mobs of the left
will take their aim at people like
us you know people who maybe
weren't necessarily all the way over on
the right
but didn't toe the line with the left
and i i actually worry that there will
be
that they they won't have as many things
to do and people to go for
and that they're still gonna need those
clicks and to make that money and
so where does that energy go hey bridget
don't worry
cancel culture is a myth it doesn't
exist we're going to be fine
only only only people who never say the
wrong thing
get to say that and so i always laugh
when people say that i'm like yeah
you're
it's always the in group saying that the
people who are saying that are always on
the in group i'm like oh
yeah you you wouldn't know what this is
actually like because
you've never been on the wrong side of a
mob of people who
is trying to come for your job your
family's jobs
and your your future children's college
educations
you know it's it's insanity yeah
yeah they always they're the ones who
always say yeah yeah why don't you just
say the right things and everything will
be fine
my yeah just say what we want and
you'll be fine disagree with us what's
the problem
what is it yeah i'm trying to get us to
the positive point
i'm trying to get us to the positive
point you talked about the pushback in
comedy
right do you see that because you know
we talk a lot about how
politics is downstream of culture uh the
culture
shapes everything else and and comedy is
often the canary in the coal mine for
processes that then go on to happen
do you think the fact that we're
starting to see that and by that
it will be very funny to see all the
comedians who've been woke for the last
five years suddenly
become really really uh edgy
yeah but but do you think that happening
will start to
take us to a say in a place
um great
thank you very much i'm i'm i'm trying
to be hopeful because i do
see i do i think as long as we're
allowed to speak
yes but a lot of it rests on
how much they're going to try and crack
down on anybody who's
pushing back against the the ideology
of woke-ism you know i think that
the stuff you see around trans activism
is
like bananas insane and
for instance with the elliot page stuff
recently
this is somebody who got famous as you
know identifying as a woman with a
female name and if you
misidentified her two seconds later most
people don't know what dead naming is if
you drove around
america and said do you know what dead
naming is i would say
probably one out of 25 people might
actually know what that even means
and they people were calling them bigots
for
you know dead naming somebody that they
knew as famous
two minutes late to give people some
time
you know like that's what that's what
is that's what's um concerning to me is
the
the lack of time people everybody
assumes the worst
oh you called her ellen him ellen
and therefore you're dead naming this
person who two minutes ago
you knew as ellen it's like can can you
have some compassion and maybe give
people
a chance to to try and get their minds
around something that's
pretty new and and i don't know
that's what's kind of chilling to me is
that you'll see something like that and
then it's like someone will get banned
from twitter
you know that that's like because they
i don't know not not maliciously
accidentally
made a mistake and
this is where i feel like
i see a lot of the energy going so i
i'm i'm optimistic that as long as
comedians are allowed to speak and to
make jokes
that they're that i think people are
like have had it but there's so much
fear in the culture
people are terrified i was on have you
been on clubhouse have you guys heard
clubhouse
no most couple so club it's a new app
social media but it's all audio and you
can enter these rooms
or be invited as like a speaker and then
you can also just observe
and i was like wow come for the group
therapy and stay for the struggle
session because i went into a room and
it was essentially
a woman got kicked out because she maybe
she
uh she just floated the idea
that hate speech um
isn't violence and they booted her out
of the room and then they let her come
back in
to rethink what she had said and to
apologize essentially
and listening to the people try and pick
their words
i mean it was because you see this on
twitter and you're like oh this can't
really be
real like these are all parodies but
then i went into this room and you're
hearing the voices and the conversations
and
just the level of fear and like you
could basically tell
where on the kind of intersectional
pyramid somebody
was by how freely they spoke and
how carefully they chose their words was
how
far down on the power dynamic they were
essentially like everybody who was
white was choosing
every single word walking
on those eggshells waiting
to step on that landmine at any given
moment and it
i was like wow this is this is not good
this is if this goes mainstream we are
in trouble
that that kind of fear of of
saying the wrong thing and in many ways
it is going mainstream we're seeing it
you're seeing
you're seeing it in corporations you're
seeing it i mean i hear this all the
time
from people in my email where people
write about being politically homeless
or self-censoring
and that is a dangerous trend
and i'm not sure i feel like the only
way out of it is to just keep speaking
people like us to just keep like i said
i'm like there are hills i will die on
and i'm gonna keep saying those things
until you ban me because
i have to until until
i don't it's like not being able to say
for instance
men and women are biologically different
i will i'm gonna die on that hill like
okay
that's we i have to there are just
certain things that
you you're not gonna like gaslight me
into
compelled speech essentially and and
that might
cost me a platform eventually but i i'm
doing things to kind of shore
i see this is where i see the free
markets kind of
um working you know like dave rubin's
thing locals is great because i know i'm
at least gonna get a phone call and i
can upload my videos directly there
and i can it operates a lot like twitter
and i have a lot of freedom to say
whatever and
we have an amazing group of all free
thinkers so
but then i see stuff happening like with
you know
mastercard and visa and you see the
financial systems getting involved in
what people can and can't
say and kicking people off patreon and
and forcing you know
like companies to behave certain ways
and i'm like
we might but then there's bitcoin so
it's all
it's all we live in these crazy times
guys
i'm happy yeah happy new year
and as somebody who's profoundly uh
pessimistic and negative
thank you for that answer bridgette and
for confirming my world view in heaven
you know what our audience always
complained that he looks incredibly
tense
uncomfortable and unfriendly look at his
happy little face right now
guys look at him he's delighted
absolutely delighted i still think that
uh i mean i can't get over it's the face
of genuine happiness
look at him everything's like looking
for me struggling to find the silver
lining and all this and i do
see it look i see it andrew schultz was
like a silver lining his netflix special
that's a silver lining tim dillon silver
lining the guy is doing great he's
crushing it
joe rogan is on spotify that is his main
stream as it gets he has held the center
for many of us
i am optimistic that the people
will you know that that this this
trend continues you guys are killing it
doing amazing you know why why are you
afraid
because we just had a video with a
million views taken down by youtube
because it doesn't comply with who
uh regulations uh but but uh
you're right
look at his happy little face uh
no but you're right you're right i think
uh
you and i certainly in agreement on one
thing which is
as long as big tech censorship doesn't
get a lot worse
which it probably will but if it doesn't
everything will be great
i do genuinely believe that welcome to
this
episode of trigonometry we're [ __ ]
that will be the title bridge of fantasy
we are [ __ ]
bridget look it's been uh it's been a
lot of fun chatting actually i'm i'm
really pleased we got you on the show
thank you for having me no it's been
great it's been fantastic
uh we'd love to have you back at some
point but for now
uh our last question which we always ask
all our guests
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we
really should be as a society oh gosh
there's so many things
i'm i'm worried about the state of um
mental health really and i know we're
talking about it but i don't know that
we're
we're doing a great job of addressing
the problems and
i think there's a there's a lot of lip
service paid to mental health but it
doesn't seem like people are
doing any better in that department in
fact it seems like things are getting a
lot worse
so there's a big disconnect for all the
talk where
we have about like mental health
awareness day and it's like
is mental health awareness day just like
hey i'm crazy
[Laughter]
because in some respects it's become
um like a cool thing to be i went down
this crazy
rabbit hole of young adults
switching from one personality to
another and these videos had
millions of views i i've never had a
video
my you switched personality in the
course of this interview away from a
miserable [ __ ]
look how happy you are now unbelievable
this is what i'm going to do bridget i
now know how to cheer him up i'm just
going to tell him everything will be
really really bad
and everybody's going to suffer and he
will be so happy
but don't do you think that things are
going
okay my one can i ask you guys a
question
sure have you heard of agenda 2030
no but i'm sure i'm gonna love it people
keep talking about it in the chat but
there's there's a lot of stuff going on
isn't there no i know it's just funny
because
we went down on dumpster fire my youtube
show we went down
somebody my one of my
my roommate is like she kind of brings
up the wing of the conspiracy
she's the voice of all the conspiracy
theories of the internet
she loves them and goes down all these
rabbit holes and
and it's just you know
every day it's like when alex jones
becomes
more and more correct you know and when
every day when
when you're like she'll send an article
and she'll be like agenda 2030.
is this some great reset do you guys
do we've heard about this look i'll tell
you what bridget
i do not i purposely ignore conspiracy
theories now in 2020 because i know if i
delve into them i'm going to [ __ ]
believe them at this point
you know so i'm just staying well away
from that [ __ ] because i don't want to
have to find myself
with a tin full hack going on about how
bill gates wants to inject everyone with
poison
like bill gates has become a villain and
i know there are people in your comments
who are going to be like
actually he is me
so let's wrap this up i don't want them
back but
i i think you're right talking about
mental health because for all as you say
for all the lip service we give it
actually you lock people in their homes
for six months
you give them nothing but social media
and twelve hundred dollars
in the united states and then you tell
them the world is ending and
you know orange man bad is killing
everyone
yeah you're gonna have some problems
with mental health it's it's like a
virtual
it's a it's like the it's like um
psychological hunger games you're not
actually like fighting out there for
anything against people you're just
locked up and it's like whose brain
isn't gonna break
bridget it's been fantastic chatting
with you before we let you go
uh tell everybody where they can find
your brilliant stuff you put out a lot
of stuff obviously your twitter and uh
dumpster fire and everything else that
you do so
you can find me on twitter at bridget
fettesey you can find me on instagram
and all the things as well
under that name but i live pretty much
on twitter and
fedexy.com is my community where we
have a great thing going we do workouts
we really
focus a lot on what we can control and
mental health and taking care of our
selves and diet and and supporting each
other
um and you can also find me on youtube i
have
a youtube channel fetishy and i have a
show dumpster fire which makes fun of
all the things
and then i have a podcast watkins
welcome which you guys should definitely
come visit me on where we talk about
grit and resilience and i hear people's
stories and
we just it's a little more more nuanced
and less of
like dumpster fire is very much my
twitter kind of in real life
and yeah oh and i have a column a
monthly columnist spectator magazine
which is always extremely good and very
very funny and we'd obviously be very
happy to to come on the podcast so
bridget thank you so much for your time
we really appreciate it i think our fans
would have loved this show
so thanks very much and we'll see you
very soon take care guys
uh have a good one and we'll see you at
7 p.m uh with a live stream or
another brilliant episode and episodes
are always wednesday and sunday and live
streams always tuesday
thursday friday and saturday see you
soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word